Allison brings you guys back because she
needs your help with Charlotte but an
event occurs that that forces you guys
to stay in Rosewood and out of that
event a new Big Bad is born the big bad
we can tell you what happens if we get
back to Rosewood
however the girls begin to again receive
messages they know it's not from
Charlotte and this time it feels very
different it's not just a manipulation
game there's something that's very very
dark and twisted it this time it's no
longer about I'm gonna expose some
secret that you have where I'm gonna you
know ruin your chances of getting like
The Orchid scholarship you know what I
mean it's paranoia blackmail it's a
life-threatening situation he's coming
for you we have to go now Allison we
came back here for you Ali so move it
it's too late he's already here because
it's life or death so quickly and you
guys fight back who right away you're
not victims you're you're like on top of
this right away and I think that's a big
difference between moving forward in the
past but you're still really good at
this I've got a lot of practice